coercive control has been an offence in
the uk since
2015 but what is it is the law working
and how can you spot whether it's
happening to you
under the serious crimes act the
following must be true for someone to be
convicted of this offence
that the abuser is personally connected
to the victim their behavior has had a
serious effect on the victim and the
abuser knew or ought to have known that
their behavior would have a serious
effect on you your abuser's behavior is
considered to have a serious effect if
on at least two occasions the victim has
feared that violence will be used
against them or they have felt serious
alarm or distress and it has had a
substantial effect on their usual
day-to-day activities before this law
the only way that domestic abusers were
convicted was if they were physically
assaulting victims but coercive control
is far more subtle than that and more
difficult to spot especially as victims
become further detached from family and
friends
the impact of coercive control varies
between victims but a really common
response is post traumatic stress
disorder this can physically alter the
victim's brain and ability to function
the amygdala which triggers the body's
responses to stress is put on high alert
by the constant abuse and can actively
warp a person's ability to react
rationally and see things clearly
[Music]
because of the nature of this crime
victims themselves might not even know
what's happening to them
here are the key signs that's happening
to you or someone you know
isolating you from friends and family
monitoring your time spying on your
social media or devices taking control
over aspects of your everyday life such
as where you can go who you can see what
you can wear and when you can sleep
depriving you access to support services
such as medical
repeatedly putting you down such as
saying you're worthless humiliating
degrading or dehumanizing you
controlling your finances
making threats or intimidating you
depriving you of basic needs
[Music]
mental abuse is the most difficult thing
to
explain to people i think that over the
years mine
was like a drip feed
coming at me
and it came to a crescendo at the end
sally chalan had been convicted of
murdering her husband who'd emotionally
abused her for many years in a landmark
decision her murder conviction was
overturned in 2019 thanks to this law
the court took into consideration that
she had been coercively controlled the
court that convicted her wasn't able to
take into account the psychological
effect that being in that sort of
abusive relationship will have had on
her and on her mental state
and the state she was in when she killed
her partner
while her case showed just how powerful
an impact coercive control could have on
victims the law hasn't transformed the
justice system in the way that some
campaigners would have wanted the number
of coercive control offences recorded by
the police increased from 4246
in 12 months across 2016 and 2017
to 24
856
in 12 months across 2019 and 2020
in 2019 just 1
112 defendants were prosecuted for these
offenses
a government review acknowledged that
the crime is likely to be far more
prevalent but there are issues in both
victims and police recognizing the crime
i think what is necessary rather than
more legislation
is better training
for
police of recognizing when the situation
is dangerous and when an offense needs
to be charged
if you want to speak to someone about
the issues we've raised here are some
numbers you can call